from Boston tonight we have a nightmare
story of random crime and violent death
October 23rd
1989 a 911 call comes into to State
Police dispatch what's your name sir
Stewart Stewart he's been a murder at
Mission Project my wife's been shot I've
been shot husband and wife who was
pregnant the steart case is the ultimate
truth serum of the city of Boston Boston
was stunned by the murder of a pregnant
woman her husband Charles is still
hospitalized when crimes happen in
certain parts of Boston forced his way
into their car were shot by a black man
we all fit the
description cities are naturally
segregated Boston takes it to an extreme
let us go to our neighborhoods where my
kids the 70s were a very tumultuous time
in Boston there was persistent racial
violence You' heard this Legend of
Boston as a birthplace of democracy but
then we also have another history as
well
[Music]
Rocky that people will just call this
the most racist City in
america3 I instructed the police
commissioner to be as aggressive as they
ever have been before they told my house
fall apart they drove me down to South
Boston I was a a scared kid how do you
happen to come here tonight flying Free
Will own free will that's not true when
you're police your job is to investigate
all aspects a murder that grabbed the
nation's attention takes a bizarre turn
this story didn't add up we've been
waiting for this case to be
Uncorked when you start connecting all
of these dots it creates a really ugly
puzzle we knew what was about to happen
this is going to end badly for
[Music]
everybody